GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING OF A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS.
SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WELCOME TO THIS MEETING THIS
AFTERNOON.
FIRST WE HAVE -- LOOK THAT MAKES
ME HERE'S BILLS AND SIGN IN
ORDER WE HAVE TEN ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY FOR ITEMS ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT INCLUDING.
I AM NUMBER FOUR SB TWO FORTY
NINE NIELSEN.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN WILK ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB SIX NINETY NINE HILL.
AND THEN ITEM NUMBER TEN SB
SEVEN EIGHTY NINE GOVERNMENT AND
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE --
LET'S SEE DO WE HAVE A QUORUM
ROOM WE DON'T WILL START UP
OPERATE SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE'LL START WITH ITEM NUMBER.
THREE SB TWO THIRTY FIVE DODD.
SEASON SENATOR DODD [inaudible]
WELCOME WELL.
THIS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU LIKE
RUNNING UP THE STAIRS I HEAR YOU --
LIFE ENERGY OTHER FACES.
WELL MADAM CHAIR AND AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT SB.
TWO THIRTY FIVE THIS IS A
DISTRICT A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW
THE CITY THE COUNTY TO EXPEDITE
THE PRODUCTION OF CRITICAL
CRITICALLY NEEDED.
HOUSING UNITS INCLUDING DEED
RESTRICTED UNITS FOR VERY LOW
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE CITY COUNTY. TO
REACH A MUTUALLY ACCEPTABLE
AGREEMENT TO ALLOW ONEOF THOSE
JURISDICTIONS. TO REPORT IT'S ON
ITS ANNUAL HOUSING PRODUCTION
REPORT. TO EIGHT C. D. THOSE
ENTITLEMENTS BUILDING PERMITS
AND CERTIFICATES OF OCCUPANCY
ISSUED BY THE OTHER JURISDICTION
FOR DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING IT'S
CERTAIN.
CONDITIONS ARE MET.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE UNIQUE
SITUATION WITH THE APPLE PIE
PROJECT IT WILL HELP THE PROJECT
MOVED FORWARD AFTER.
NEARLY TEN YEARS A CONVERSATIONS
AND COLLABORATIONS WITH THE
DEVELOPERS -- THE CITY IN THE
COUNTY IT DOES DAY BACK THAT
LONG BECAUSE I WAS ON THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AT THAT TIME THAT
WE MADE THIS.
HAPPEN THE CITY COUNTY ENTERED
INTO NUMEROUS AGREEMENTS
OUTLINING FUTURE ENTITLEMENTS
ANNEXATION TAX REVENUE SHARING
AND PROVISION OF MUNICIPAL
SERVICES AND POTABLE WATER.
BY THE CITY OF NAPA IN LIEU OF
USING USING GROUND.
WATER ALL THIS WAS WORKED OUT TO
A MULTI PHASE DEVELOPMENT
AGREEMENT WHICH IS UNDER WAY.
HOWEVER AFTER EVALUATING CURRENT
MARKET CONDITIONS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE SCENARIOS THE
DEVELOPER DETERMINE THAT SOME OF
THE HOUSING NEEDED TO BE MOVED.
TO THE FIRST PHASE OF THE
DEVELOPMENT ON THE LAND ALREADY
ANNEXED TO THE CITY.
SO IN SHORT THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT WE'VE GOT
TO GO BACK AND TRY TO UNDO THAT
ALLOW.
THE CITY ACCOUNTED TO HAVE THAT
ARRANGEMENT ON THAT FIRST PARCEL --
WITH ME TODAY IS -- STE COUNTY
SUPERVISOR WRITING GREGORY MAYOR --
JOEL TACKLE FROM THE CITY MAP.
WELCOME TAG TEAM HELLO.
MANAGER THANK YOU MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IS THAT
SUPPORT SUPPORT IT IS A SUPPORT
SUPPORT SO WE PROBABLY CAN.
LIMIT THE COMMENTS AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE FAST SOUNDS LIKE I
MISSED A PLANE MAKE SURE IT WILL.
BASS I JUST GET A WE OPERATE.
SO YOU CAN MAKE YOUR IS THIS
YOUR STATEMENT SHORT.
THANK YOU.
SURE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AND AND FOR BEING OUR ASSEMBLY
PERSON AND FOR ALL THE WORK YOU
DO NAPA COUNTY -- THIS IS ABOUT
IT SO YOU HEARD A LOT OF HOUSING
BILLS THIS YEAR THIS IS THIS
ONCE.
FUN BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT GETTING A
PROJECT STARTED NEXT SPRING
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT --
NINE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE UNIT
PROJECT FOR NOW BUT THE SINGLE
BIGGEST A RESIDENTS PROJECT IN
OUR HISTORY -- WITH THIS
LEGISLATION WILL START NEXT YEAR
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT NAPA
COUNTY IN THE CITY OF NAPA --
IT'S ALSO A CELEBRATION OF THE
WAY THE CITY AND COUNTY ARE
WORKING TOGETHER TO DEAL WITH
OUR HOUSING CHALLENGES AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW NAPA AS MUCH OF A
ROLE NAPA IS DEDICATED
AGRICULTURE SO WE HAVE TO WORK
WITH OUR CITY WE GET TO WORK
WITH OUR CITY PARTNERS.
I IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH THE
HOUSING THAT OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS
SO THIS IS A CELEBRATION OF US
GETTING TOGETHER AND WORKING ON
THIS -- TOWARDS A POSITIVE
OUTCOME -- WITH THAT MAYOR
TACKLE.
YEAH IF WE'RE TAKING WE'RE GOOD
TAKE TEAM BECAUSE WE'RE HERE
TOGETHER GOING IN THE SAME
DIRECTION -- WE APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD ON THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE'VE CREATED
TO GET HOUSING BUILT AND MORE
PARTLY FOR THE LOCALS THEY
REALLY DO WANT THAT COSCO SO.
IF WE CAN GET MOVING ON THIS
PROJECT THAT WILL BE APPRECIATED
BACK IN OUR OUR COMMUNITY.
WE ALL WILL BE.
OKAY AND ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
SINGERS ANYBODY THE POSING THE
BILL.
SO RECESS IN THE NORTHWEST
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SORRY ABOUT THAT STAYS EATEN RAW
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OR TWEENER. TO CHANCE
IT.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
FROM.
AS YOU KNOW.
I LOVE THIS BILL I'D LIKE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR OF SENATOR.
I HAD TO WAIT UNTIL WE GET YOU
THROUGH THIS PLACE BUT GREAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD
WORK YOU GUYS HAVE DONE
COLLABORATIVELY THESE AWAY WE
SEE PROJECTS OFF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO I WILL PUT ON THE
PEDESTAL RIGHT NOW TO SAY SEE
WHAT NAPA DOESN'T SEE WHAT THE
PROJECT WAS SECOND STARTING IN
THE SPRING SO CONGRATULATIONS.
LINKEDIN EMOTION -- ONCE WE HAVE
A QUORUM.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THE CHORE
OVER YOUR HAPPY FOR THE JULY.
TWO TWO SEE A JOB.
NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR BELL ITEM
NUMBER ONE SP.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT WELCOME SENATOR
.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED LOOKS LIKE
WE'VE GOT A QUORUM SO -- WOULD
DO OUR DUE DILIGENCE HERE
[inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY.
HERE AGUIAR-CURRY HERE LACKEY.
LACKEY HERE BLOOM.
BLOOM HAIR BURNER HARD AFTER
RAMOS.
RAMOS HAIRLESS RIVAS ROBERT
RIVAS VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL HERE.
FEAR.
OF HELL HERE.
OKAY -- WE HAVE WITH THE STATUS
OF FORM AND CENTER BUILT BELL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO START -- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY -- TODAY I
AM PRESENTING SB -- ONE TWENTY
EIGHT THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD
EXTEND.
THE EXISTING SUNSET OF THE BEST
VALUE CONSCIOUS CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTING PROGRAM. TO ADD OF
FIVE ADDITIONAL YEARS.
AND WILL ADDS THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA TO THE PILOT.
NOW CURRENT CONTRACTS FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS ARE
SELECTED UTILIZING LOW COST
METHODS AS RESULT.
THE FACTORS SUCH AS
RESPONSIBILITY LABOR STANDARDS
DELAYS OFTEN GO OVERLOOKED IN
FAVOR THE CHEAPEST POSSIBLE
OPTION.
NOW FAVORITE FAILURE TO CONSIDER
SUCH FACTORS CAN LEAD TO AN
INCREASE IN THE TOTAL COST OF
THE PROJECT.
THE BEST VALUE CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTING PROGRAM COURAGEOUS
IT LARGER CONTRACTOR BIDDING
PULL REDUCES THE BAD ACTORS AND
INCREASES THE AMOUNT OF SKILLED
CRAFT WORKERS.
ON COUNTY CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
THE CURRENT LAW SUNSETS AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR.
WHILE MANY COUNTIES ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF IMPLEMENTING THE BEST
VALUE SELECTION PROCESS.
AND I WANT.
I WANT ALSO TO LET THE COMMITTEE
KNOW THAT MODERATE COUNTY HAS
REQUESTED TO BE INCLUDED -- IF
THERE'S NO OBJECTIONS AND I PLAN
TO A MAN -- THE BILL INCLUDING
MONTEREY COUNTY -- IF THIS BILL
IS APPROVED -- IN THE NEXT STEP
WITH THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
AND TODAY WE HAVE MARK A HOMO
FROM SOLANO COUNTY.
JONATHAN CLAY FROM -- REPRESENT
SAN DIEGO COUNTY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US TODAY I'M MORE KAMEL CAPITAL
PROJECT MANAGER FROM SOLAO
COUNTY.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF SOLANO
COUNTY TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATOR BELLS BILL. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT EXTENDING THE AVAILABILITY
OF BEST VALUE CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACT PROCUREMENT TO THE
SEVERAL COUNTIES NAMED IN THE
BILL INCLUDING SOLANO COUNTY.
SOLANO COUNTY VERY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE CHATTED ABOUT
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
RECENTLY SOLANO COUNTY
SUCCESSFULLY YOU FELT ABOUT YOUR
PROCUREMENT HAS CURRENTLY
ALLOWED UNDER THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTING CODE.
PILOT PROGRAM TO DELIVER THAT
NEW YORK VOCATIONAL TRAINING
CENTER IN FAIRFIELD.
ROCKED OCCASIONAL TRAINING
CENTER IS A NEW FORTY SIX
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT TWENTY SIX
MILLION A RE ENTRY FACILITY
OPERATED BY SOLANO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE.
THE PROJECT WAS 90% FUNDED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA UNDER
THE SUPERVISION OF THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
OFFICIALLY AUTHORIZING STATE
SENATE BILL.
TEN TWENTY TWO WITH A
CORRESPONDING 10% MATCH FROM
SOLANO COUNTY.
THOUGHT ACCOUNT REPORTERS
SUPERVISORS DRUG TO PROVE THE
NOTICE OF COMPLETION FOR THE
PROJECT ON JUNE TWENTY FIFTH AND
STAFF IS NOW DRAFTING THE
REQUIRED REPORT.
ON THE SUCCESS OF BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT FOR THE STATE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS
REQUIRED BY THE LEGISLATION.
LEGISLATION ALLOWING THE COUNTY
TO AWARD THE CONTRACT ON THE
BASIS OF BEST VALUE ATTRACTED A
HIGHLY QUALIFIED GROUP OF
CONTRACTORS TO PROPOSE ON THIS
SPECIALIZED FACILITY.
WITH QUALIFICATIONS AND
EXPERIENCE BEYOND WHAT THE
COUNTY MIGHT HAVE OTHERWISE
EXPECTED USING TRADITIONAL LOW
BID PROCUREMENT.
CONSTRUCTION CONTRA CAUGHT
PROJECT COME IN MANY SHAPES AND
SIZES BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT IS
NOT A SOLUTION FOR ALL OF THEM
BUT IT IS A OF SOLUTION FOR SOME
OF THEM.
IT IS A USEFUL TOOL TO HAVE
SOLANO COUNTY SUPPORTS THE BILL
BENNETT CRITICAL COMMITTEE TO
ADVANCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT HALF THE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO -- HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE EXTENSION OF THIS
AUTHORITY WE ARE ONE OF THE
ORIGINAL COUNTIES GRANTED THIS
AUTHORITY -- AND WE'RE ALL SAYS
NOTING THE ANNOUNCES WERE ONE OF
THOSE COUNTIES THAT ARE POISED
TO UTILIZE THIS PROGRAM BUT
HAVING UTILIZE IT YET.
UNLIKE -- WAS SOLANO COUNTY WILL
BE LOOKING AT MORE INITIALLY --
MAINTENANCE MAJOR REHABS ADA
COMPLIANCE -- THOSE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS BUT WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE CENTER BELL STEPPING
IN TO HELP US WITH THIS --
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET AND HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE OTHER
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT.
AND WE APOLOGIZE WE DID NOT GET
A LETTER NOTED WE TALK WITH YOUR
STAFF BECAUSE WE JUST TOOK THE
SUPPORT POSITION.
BUT WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU.AUDREY RETIRED CHECK FROM CRUISE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
DEFINITION MEMBERS PAT WHALEN
ELLIS MOST NAXI HERE ON BEHALF
OF GUARDIAN GROUP IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I NEED A MOTION.
OKAY SO WE'LL UP BY.
WIENER HARGA.
AND RUSS SENATOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RIVAS GOT IT.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY REJECT CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- OF MEN I'M SURE --
JERRY VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SECRETARY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS FIVE
VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL AYE.
MEASURES OF SEVEN ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU SOLANO COUNTY FOR
MAKING THE TRUCK OUT HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU BACK IN OUR NEXT IS
ITEM NUMBER TWO SP ONE THIRTY
NINE ALLEN.
MEMBERS OF THE VERY QUICK THIS --
BILL -- BASICALLY PROVIDES FOR
INDEPENDENT REGISTRY COMMISSIONS.
OF SOME OF COUNTIES A CERTAIN
SIZE -- WE WERE ALL SELECTED.
IN DISTRICTS ELECTED IN
DISTRICTS THAT WERE DRAWN UP BY
INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS --
BECAUSE I THINK THE VOTERS BY
CORRECTLY RECOGNIZE THAT IT WAS
BETTER TO HAVE.
A MORE INDEPENDENT AND FAIR
PROCESS OF WHEN IT KEEPS.
TO TO TO DRAW OAKLAND HILLS.
SO I PERCENT FASTER VOTE.
WELCOME IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK.
YOU'VE GOT YOU'VE GOT THE YOU'VE
GOT THE OF THE MOTION SO.
CHAIR MEMBERS NICHOLS HAD ON
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE WE'RE PROUDCO SPONSOR
THAT'S THE ONE THIRTY NINETY
SURE OF FAIR AND INDEPENDENT
COUNTY REDUCING PROCESS AND
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST COUNTIES.
A GERRYMANDERING IS NO PLACE OUR
DEMOCRACY TO ANY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT.
GERRYMANDERING HARMS PUBLIC
TRUST IN FAIRNESS WERE PROCESS
UNDERMINES REPRESENTED NATURE OF
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
ENTERPRISE VOTERS THE ABILITY TO
HOLD ELECTED OFFICIALS
ACCOUNTABLE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WHEN IT COMES
TO STATE AND CONGRESSIONAL
REDUCING CALIFORNIA'S DONE MORE
THAN ANY OTHER STATE TO
ELIMINATE GERRYMANDERING.
CALIFORNIA STATE CITIZENS
REDUCING COMMISSION WHICH
REMOVES FROM PROCESS AND
COMMENTS WITH NO ELECTORAL SELF
INTEREST AND HAVE LINES ARE
DRAWN.
IS CONSIDERED THE NATIONAL GOLD
STANDARD BY NOT ONLY REFORMERS
BUT ALSO ACADEMICS WHO STUDY
THIS ISSUE.
THIS BILL EXTENDS THAT BEST
PRACTICE INDEPENDENT RE DISTINCT
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST COUNTIES
LIKE THE STATE COMMISSION SB ONE
THREE NINE REQUIRES MEASURES TO
MEET STRICT ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR EXAMPLE.
PROVIDING RECENT CANDIDATES
LOBBYISTS FOR MAJOR DONORS FROM
SERVING ON THE COMMISSION.
CREATES A RANDOM SELECTION
PROCESSES TO ENSURE
COMMISSIONERS NOVEL INTENDING
FISHEL YOUR CAR'S OF THE COUNTY
TAKE FROM THE STEPS TO ENSURE
THE COMMISSIONERS REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY THE JURISDICTION.
REQUIRES A COMMISSION TACK
TRANSPARENT TRANSPARENTLY EXCUSE
ME AND HOLD MULTIPLE HEARINGS
FORMAT CAN BE ADOPTED.
INDEPENDENT REDUCING IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE LEADS MORE
REPRESENT ABOUT COMES FROM A
TRUSTED FRIENDS PROCESS FOR THAT --
I THINK YOU -- TONIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOOR ROSE.
THE RIVER IS A CALIFORNIA.
THE STATELY KELP LEAD THE FIGHT
FOR THE INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION OF THE
LATE AT THE STATE LEVEL AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL OUR LOCAL LEAGUES.
WORK -- BOTH TO TRY TO GET
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION TO PUT THE PLACE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND WHEN THEY
ARE.
IN PLACE THEY WORK ON
IMPLEMENTATION THEY WERE THERE
IN THE TRENCHES THEY ARE THEY'RE
MAKING SURE THE COMMISSIONERS
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF THE
COMMUNITY.
THAT THE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IS
REALLY ROBUST THAT ENGAGES
PEOPLE FROM THE COMMUNITY AND
THAT THE WHOLE PROCESS IS
TRANSPARENT.
AND THE REASON THAT WE DO THIS
IS BECAUSE FAIR INCLUSIVE LINE
DRAWING IS REALLY CORD A GOOD
GOVERNMENT.
WAITED LEGISLATIVE BODY DRAWS
ITS OWN LINE SIR IS NECESSARILY
AN ALWAYS A TEMPTATION TO HELP
OR HURT.
INCUMBENTS ARE POTENTIAL MEMBERS
OR TO PRESERVE POWER IN ONE
POLITICAL PARTY THESE ARE NOT
ABSTRACT CONCERNS WE'VE SEEN
THEM ALL TOO OFTEN. ONE REPORT
FASTER BY.
I DO THAT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
BASICALLY VOTERS WANT TO KNOW
THE LEXUS ARE GOING TO BE FAIR
FIGHTS THEY WANT TO KNOW THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ELECT SOMEBODY
THAT REALLY REFLECTS THE
INTERESTS OF THEIR COMMUNITY.
BY FIXING THE WAY THAT WE DRAW
THESE LOCAL LINES WILL BE ONE
STEP CLOSER TO THAT IDEAL AND
ONE STEP CLOSER REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY SO WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL IN THOSE VIEW IN SUPPORT.
SHE COULD COME IN AND CHECK.
SURE THE THANK YOU FOR COMING IN
MISTER PHONE YEAH.
I MEAN TO THE SUPPORTERS.
HEY EVAN MAINTAIN WITH
CALIFORNIA VOICES FOR PROGRESS
WHERE THE ONE PERCENTERS IN
SOCIETY WHO ADVOCATE FOR THE 99%
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
SOUTH MAIN WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AND
THE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
PRINT L<c.cyan>G CALIFORNIA MONEY</c>
CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JIM WINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SYLVIA CHIU FOR A SPECIFIC AND
MARK ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OF DRIVEN ME WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
STAND HERE BECAUSE I'M GOING TO
GIVE THE BULLET POINT VERSION OF
OUR OPPOSITION WHICH IS JUST
THAT THIS IMPLEMENT THE MANDATE --
THE MANDATES WILL HAVE TO BE
REIMBURSED BY THE STATE -- THE
STATE HAS SO FAR -- SUSPENDED
ALL OF THE OTHER ELECTION
RELATED MANDATES THAT WE FEAR
THAT THIS WILL MEET A SIMILAR
FATE WHICH WILL IN FACT MAKE IT
OPTIONAL IN LAW INSTEAD OF
REQUIRED WHICH WE THINK IS.
CONFUSING -- FOR THE PUBLIC IN
FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES AND THAT
COUNTIES -- THREE OUT OF FOUR
COUNTY STILL HAVE NOT RECOVERED --
THERE THAT DESCRIBE THEIR TAX
REVENUE SINCE THE RECESSION --
AND THIS WOULD JUST BE AN
ADDITIONAL COST THOSE ARE.
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM WITH
THE CHAIR PLEASE IDENTIFY
HIMSELF OR THE WITNESSES SAID
AND IF I'M SELF.
TRYING TO BE BRIEF AND I WAS TOO
BRIEF -- JEFF NEAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS ANOTHER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE I JEAN HEARST HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE SHARE THE SAME
CONCERNS AS THE SOCK ON ON
FISCAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OFANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE -- SELLING MEMBER OF
RICK ROSS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IT'S JUST A QUICK
QUESTION AS FAR AS WORKING WITH
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
HAVE THEY BEEN ABLE TO AGENDA IS
THIS OR HAVE HEARINGS ON THIS
PARTICULAR TOPIC WITHIN THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION [inaudible]
WELL THEY WHILE ON THIS ON THIS
BILL.
ON THIS BILL ON ON THIS PROCESS
OF OF HAVING THIS PROCESS OVER
THE EXISTING PROCESS HAS IT BEEN
VETTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL HAVING
HEARINGS MAKING SURE THAT THE
LOCAL CONSTITUENTS ARE -- GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THEIR
VOICE HEARD AT THAT LEVEL WELL
WE HAVE SO WHAT WE HAVE DONE SO
FAR IS -- WE HAVE THERE WE HAVE
PASSED LAWS THAT HAVE ALLOWED
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN TWO TIME
SWITCH OVER TO INDEPENDENT
REDUCING COMMISSIONS AND IN FACT.
WE HAVE ALREADY.
ARE REQUIRED LOS ANGELES.
AND I THINK SAN DIEGO -- AS WELL
TO DO SO SO IN THOSE AREAS --
THAT HAVE ALREADY.
DONE INDEPENDENT THIS
COMMISSIONS OR ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING AND THEY
HAVE THEY HAVE BEEN CUT.
PULLING TOGETHER THE PROCESS
ASSOCIATED WITH GETTING THESE
COMMISSIONS TOGETHER AND THEN --
AND THEN HAVING TO DRAW THE
LINES IN THIS WOULD END UP.
THEN NOW DICTATING TO THE
COUNTIES -- THE TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD IN THIS COMMISSION
SAID SO THE WAY IT'S STRUCTURED
IS -- RIGHT NOW THE WAY IT'S
WRITTEN I THINK COUNTIES OVER --
SEVEN FIFTY THOUSAND AND THEN
COUNTIES BETWEEN TWO FIFTY AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION.
AND IS ONE THING WE HAVE TO
MENTION AND WE'VE TAKEN SOME
AMENDS TO MAKE -- THIS PROCESS
SIGNIFICAN LESS EXPENSIVE THAT
HAVE BEEN INITIALLY ANTICIPATED.
I THINK MOST OF THE INITIAL
REACTION FROM THE COUNTIES WAS
THEY WORRY ABOUT EXPENSE -- BUT
NOW THAT WE HAVE THE GRAND JURY
CONTRIVING THE THE THE THE
SELECTION PROCESS.
FOR BUSY ADMINISTERING THE
SELECTION PROCESS FOR THE
COMMISSIONERS IT'S SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS EXPENSIVE BECAUSE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO CONVENE A BRAND NEW BODY
TO DO THAT.
AND SO WHERE WHERE WE'RE BECAUSE
THERE WERE CONCERNS IN YOUR
COUNTERPART COMMITTEE OVER ON
THE SENATE SIDE THAT THAT --
THIS MAY BE TOO EXPENSIVE FOR
SMALLER COUNTIES WE'VE FOCUSED
ON THE LARGER COUNTIES --
WHETHER BE LESS OF AN IMPACT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE MUCH BIGGER
BUDGETS AND THE TOTAL COST.
EYES WITH AN ESTIMATE TO BE A
LITTLE LESS TO A THOUSAND WITH
THAT THANK YOU FOR THAT SENATOR
AND THE CONCERN.
THAT I HAVE IT AS FAR AS BEING
ABLE TO HAVE THE PROCESS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WITH THE COUNTIES
BEING ABLE TO AGENDA IS IT HAVE
A HEARING.
HERE FROM THE LOCAL CONSTITUENTS
ON SOMETHING MOVING FORWARD IN
THIS AREA I DON'T AGREE WITH
WITH.
I'D I DON'T DISAGREE WITH THE
WHERE THE BILL IS HEADED I JUST
THINK THAT THERE HAS TO BE MORE.
INPUT FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL MOM
WITH THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HAVING HEARINGS AGENDAS UNIT
MAKING SURE THAT'S OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC AND HAVING THAT MOVE AND
BY THE WAY THAT IS ACTUALLY
BUILT INTO THIS PROCESS SO SO.
FOR THIS TO BE IMPLEMENTED THEY
HAVE TO HAVE FIVE HEARINGS OVER
THE PUBLIC THERE'S A IS A VERY
OPEN PROCESS ASSOCIATED WITH
BOTH THE SELECTION.
AND THEN THE AND AND AND AND
THEN COME MONITORING THEM THE
MAP TRYING PROCESS THAT GOES
FORWARD SO THERE'S A VERY REAL
BLAST.
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT ASPECT TO THIS
BILL BUT CERTAINLY HAPPY TALK TO
YOU ABOUT.
BY STRENGTHENING IT IF THAT'S OF
INTEREST TO YOU. SEVEN LOOK
FORWARD TO FOR THE DIALOGUE OKAY.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SEEING NONE WE HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND TO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
NO JUST VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
THE HARD WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
AS THEY SAY -- THIS IS NOT GOING
TO BE I'M.
YEAH WE REALLY MADE SURE THAT
THIS IS NOT GOING TO HAVE A
MAJOR FISCAL IMPACT ON THE ON
THE COUNTIES AND WE'RE VERY VERY
COMMITTED.
TO A FAIR ROBUST PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT BUT THIS IS
ULTIMATELY ABOUT MAKING SURE THE
LINES ARE DRAWN IN A FAIR WAY --
AND HAVING AN INDEPENDENT GROUP
DO THAT WE DO THAT VERY
SUCCESSFULLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE LINES I CAN
RATIONALIZE FORTY CAUSATION
LINES TOWARDS VERY WELL FOR US.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE FOR THE SAME FAIRNESS
PRINCIPLES TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHEN IT COMES
TO SELECTING -- SUPERVISORS
WITHOUT ASK FOR HAVE A GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO RING THE
BELL A BILL FORD AND I AM MAKING
THE EFFORT TO REDUCE REDUCE THE
IMPACTS ON OUR SMALLER -- COUNTY
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND
SECRETARY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HER OF THAT.
RAMOS.
RAMOS SNOW THREE OF US THREE OF
US FIVE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I A VOEPEL.
THE POUND NO.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES AS
AN APPOINTEE OF FOR LET ME GO
OUT OF ORDER.
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE PERSON
MISSING OR WHERE TO GO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR --
NEXT WILL BE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
THREE FIFTY FIVE SENATOR
PORTANTINO WELL THE BILL.
THAT ONE DAY AGO.
I HAVE A MOTION A SECOND SO THAT
NOTION YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
THAT YES -- THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
DISTRICT BILL THAT MAKES SENSE
FOR THE CLEAN POWER ALLIANCE AND
I HAVE WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT
AND I'LL JUST LET THEM DO THEIR
THING.
WELL THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DIANA
MAHMOUD I'M A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER FROM THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA AND THE CHAIR OF THE
CLEAN POWER ALLIANCE AND I WILL
HAVE TO ADD A VETERAN OF THE
ELECTRIC UTILITY INDUSTRY.
PRE DATING THE ENERGY CRISIS
CLEAN POWER ALLIANCE IS THE
LARGEST CCA IN THE STATE WE'RE
CURRENTLY SERVING OVER A MILLION.
ACCOUNTS WE CONSIST OF TWENTY
NINE CITIES AND TWO COUNTIES OUR
GPA PROVIDES FOR EACH MEMBERS
ABILITY TO DESIGNATE TWO
ALTERNATES -- AND ONE OF THOSE
ALTERNATES -- CAN BE EITHER
STAFF OR A MEMBER OF THAT
AGENCIES PUBLIC HOWEVER THAT
MEMBER HAS TO HAVE EXPERTISE IN
ENERGY MATTERS.
WE'VE JUST COMPLETED ROLL OUT TO
ALL OF OUR MEMBERS EXCEPT FOR
ONE THAT VERY RECENTLY JOINED
THERE ARE MULTIPLE MATTERS BEING
LITIGATED -- THAT AFFECTS CCA
OPERATIONS IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN CLOSED SESSION
DISCUSSIONS AND SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE ROUTINELY
REPRESENTED BY NON ELECTED TO
AND UNDER.
THE CURRENT STATE OF THE LAW THE
NON ELECTED ARE NOT ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN CLOSED SESSION
DISCUSSIONS AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD REMEDY.
I'M WE AGREE WITH STAFF'S
ANALYSIS THAT WOULD SUGGEST THAT
CLARIFICATION BE PROVIDED IN THE
BILL -- TO PRESERVE THE CLOSED
SESSION CONFIDENTIALITY -- AND
TO PROVIDE FOR THE MEMBER AGENCY
DESIGNATION OF THEIR ALTERNATES
RATHER THAN THE GPAS DESIGNATION
OF MEMBER ALTERNATES I'M OUR GPA.
AGREEMENT ITSELF ARE ORGANIC
DOCUMENT ALREADY REQUIRES AT ITS
CONFLICT OF INTEREST POLICY
APPLY TO ALL DESIGNATED --
DIRECTORS AND ALTERNATES --
ADDITIONALLY WE'VE RECENTLY GONE
ABOVE AND BEYOND AND ADOPTED
DEFENDER COMMUNICATION POLICY
THAT APPLIES TO ALL DIRECTORS
ALTERNATES OR NOT -- AND AND
ALTHOUGH WE WE THINK THAT ARE
THAT THE BILL AS PRESENTLY
DRAFTED REPRESENTS GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY IF THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD
DECIDE TO LIMIT IT TO CPA WE CAN
LIVE WITH THAT THE IMPORTANT
THING IS THAT WE GET THE RELIEF
THAT.
IS -- SOUGHT BY THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FAITH
BORDERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES JUST VERY
BRIEFLY I WE PLOT THE AUTHOR'S
EFFORTS ON BEHALF OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CENTER DR ED AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY%
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF WE HAVE A MOTION
ALREADY DID I BELIEVE.
OKAY I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
EVER MOTION A SECOND -- SO
MEMBER BLOOM AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALMOST -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO A
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS COMMITTEE.
NO OTHER THREE DID THAT OKAY
SORRY -- WHICH I CLOSE.
JUST -- ARE THERE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SHOULD LIKELY TO TAKE OR
WELL YES I WAS WAITING FOR YOU
TO SAY THAT.
THAT'S WHY I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE THE MOTION WAS -- I AM
ACCEPTING THE COMPANY AMENDMENTS
AND SO IT'S MOVED AS AMENDED BY.
GOING TO REMIND YOU.
I'VE BEEN A HOT WELL.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING OUR COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THE TO KNOW THE BILL
ENSURE CONFIDENTIALITY OF CLOSE
SESSIONS IS PROTECTED -- WILL BE
SUPPORTING THAT YOUR BILL TODAY
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THANK
[inaudible]
SECRETARY.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I A
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM BLOOM AYE
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS
RAMESSIDE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I MEASURE.
THERE'S THAT IS ZERO AND SINCE
WE LIKE TO SO MUCH SENATOR WE'D
LIKE YOU TO STAY WITH US AND
PRESENT YOUR BILL NUMBER I DON'T
NUMBER.
EIGHT SB FIVE THIRTY TWO THANK
YOU -- MADAM CHAIR I FORGOT TO
DO.
MY DUE DILIGENCE MY EXPERT
WITNESS -- DIANA MAHMOUD IS A
COUNCIL MEMBER IN THE GREAT CITY
OF SOUTH PASADENA SO I WANNA
MAKE SURE SHE GETS A SHOUT OUT --
I'M ALSO PRESENTING SB -- FIVE
THIRTY TWO MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE CITY OF GLENDALE TO USE THE
REMAINING BOND PROCEEDS FROM
THEIR TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
SUBORDINATE TAXABLE TAX
ALLOCATION BOND FOR THE PURPOSE
OF INCREASING.
IMPROVING AND PRESERVING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THIS PART OF
THE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN BUDGET
ACT APPROVAL WAS GRANTED
DISSOLVING THE STATE'S FOUR
HUNDRED PLUS REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES.
I VOTED AGAINST THAT DISSOLUTION
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
PROUD TO HAVE DONE THAT.
THESE AGENTS THE SERVE AS AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT I
REDEVELOPMENT PROVIDED THE
LARGEST ONGOING SOURCE OF
REVENUE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN CALIFORNIA.
AS A LOCAL REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES PROVIDED ROUGHLY ONE
BILLION ANNUALLY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
WHEN REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES WERE
CLOSED -- CALIFORNIA REMOVE THIS
FINANCING BUT ALSO LAUGHED SOME
CITIES WITH -- SOME DOLLARS IN
THIS CASE GLENDALE HAD A TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN SUPPORT IT
TAXABLE ALLOCATION BOND AND
AMOUNT OF APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
OF NON HOUSING DOLLARS FROMTHE
CENTRAL GLENDALE WE'RE ALL OF IT
REDEVELOPMENT PROJECT AREA THAT
IT IS PREVENTED FROM UTILIZING
BY THE STATE BECAUSE IT IS NOT
ALLOWED UNDER THE DISSOLUTION.
ACT TO BE USED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO RATHER THAN DE FEES
OR CANCEL THIS BOND GLENDALE HAS
REQUESTED TO DELEGATE IT TOWARDS
1100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS -- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO LEVERAGE THESE DOLLARS TO
BUILD UPWARDS OF FOUR HUNDRED
DEDICATED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS AND THAT'S A LAUDABLE GOAL
AND SO FUNDAMENTALLY WANT TO
KEEP LOCAL DOLLARS LOCAL AND
GIVE THE CITY -- LOCALLY DRIVEN
DISCRETION TO USE THEM
EXCLUSIVELY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH ME I HAVE FILL
LANDS OF FAME FROM THE GREAT
CITY OF GLENDALE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
BEN AND JERRY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR TAKING THIS BILL TODAY
GLENDALE IS COMMITTED TO
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
AS WELL AS MARKET RATE HOUSING --
WE ARE ARE WE ARE INTERESTED IN
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE FUNDS AND
PROGRAMS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
ON HOUSING -- BUT THEY'LL TAKE
SOME TIME TO IMPLEMENT THIS WILL
GIVE US FUNDS IMMEDIATELY TO PUT
INTO A PRODUCTION WE'RE LOOKING
NOW AT TWO PIECES OF PROPERTY IN
MY CITY COUNCIL BE VOTING ON
THAT NEXT WEEK.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS -- THEN TO
SUPPORT THOSE PROJECTS AND AS
THE SENATOR SAID BUILD UP TO
FOUR HUNDRED NEW UNITS ARE USING
THESE DOLLARS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
PORTANTINO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IPHONE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY ANYONE
HERE TO OPPOSE THE BILL
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NANCY CHAD
ASSISTING US ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING AND THE CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S GOAL TO
TRY TO HELP THE CITY OF GLENDALE
PRODUCE MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
BUT WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
DIVERSION OF PROPERTY TAXES
COULD HURT EDUCATION FUNDING
OVER THE LONG TERM.
AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
MECHANISM FOR A GENERAL FUND
BACK FILL OF THOSE PROPERTY
TAXES THAT ARE SHIFTED AWAY FROM
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES IN
THE SHORT TERM.
WHAT I'M REFERRING TO IS THAT
THAT MECHANISM ITSELF MAKES
EDUCATION -- MORE RELIABLE ON
THE VOLATILE GENERAL FUND OVER
THE LONGER TERM THAT RELATIVELY
STABLE PROPERTY TAXES AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE RISK -- DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION OF THE LAST
DECADE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS
LIKE FIFTY SIXTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING DUE TO BUDGET
CUTS AND PROP NINETY EIGHT
SUSPENSION WHICH HAVE NEVER BEEN
RESTORED SO WITH CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY FORTY FIRST IN
EDUCATION FUNDING.
THE COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
SCHOOL HOUSING IN THE CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
IN THE IN QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
I NEED A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- ROMMEL'S AND THE
SECOND BY SOME REMEMBER RIVAS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM --
I FIVE I LOVE THE WHEN PEOPLE
TRY TO FIND NEW WAYS -- FOR
HOUSING I THINK THIS IS A VERY
CREATIVE WAY TO BRING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO COMMUNITIES -- I
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION'S
COMMENT BUT HOWEVER IF WE DON'T
HAVE HOUSING.
THAT MAKES IT EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT TO HELP US WITH THE
TEACHERS AND MOVING COMMUNITIES
FORWARD WITH EDUCATION SO.
I SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY AND
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING.
FOR OKAY -- SECRETARY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMOS SILOS RIVAS IS RIVAS AYE
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL.
AYE VOEPEL AYE.
MEASURES OUT EIGHT ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND NOW WE HAVE A ITEM
NUMBER.
FIVE THE SP TWO NINETY THREE
CELL A SENATOR SKINNER WELCOME.
RIGHT A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH IT IS
I AM WITH THE MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SO HE GOT THROUGH THE
REGION THE PERFECT.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- TO IN A
SECOND.
JUST PICK ONE OVER THERE.
I DON'T CARE WHO YOU PICK.
AGUIAR-CURRY OKAY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I'VE BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMESSIDE THREE OF US THREE OF
US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL LIKE
VOEPEL HI.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT WILL
MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY BILL OF
THOSE WHOSE ME SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY THREES WELCOME SENATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
FIRST I WANT TO SAY I AM COULD
TAKING THE COMMITTEES ARE
CLARIFYING AND TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS.
AND I COULD READ THEM BUT I
THINK YOU HAVE THEM SO I'LL JUST
LEAVE IT AT THAT GREAT.
OKAY GOOD GOOD ALL RIGHT NO MR
THERE'S LITTLE TOUCHES IT IS
YEAH WATCHES NO WORRIES NO
WORRIES I'M SUPPOSED TO BE IT TO
OTHER PLACES BUT THAT'S COOL I
LOVE BEING HERE.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
ASSISTS THE CITY OF OAKLAND.
BECAUSE THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCE LAWS ARE
NOT SUFFICIENT TO ALLOW THEM TO
DO THE INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND A
PROPOSED PRIVATELY FINANCED
STADIUM.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS MAKE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT MORE FEASIBLE FOR THE
CITY OF OAKLAND TO USE AND I
COULD GIVE YOU ALL THESE REASONS
WHY IT MAKES IT EASIER FOR THEM
BUT I HAVE THESE WONDERFUL.
WITNESSES SO ALL LET THEM TALK I
HAVE CITY COUNCIL MEMBER LORD
TAYLOR FROM THE CITY OF OAKLAND
I HAVE DAVE OF ALL FROM THE
OAKLAND EIGHTIES GO ETS -- WHICH
IS THE STADIUM THE PRIVATE
STADIUM THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AND I HAVE ROB STOKER FROM OUR
ALAMEDA COUNTY BUILDING TRADES.
HEY WELCOME GERMAN THANK YOU.
GREETINGS OUTSIDE CHAIRPERSON
IDEA CURRY -- MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME'S LAWRENCE TAYLOR I'M A
COUNCIL MEMBER FROM THE CITY OF
OAKLAND AND ONE EXPRESS
OAKLAND'S SUPPORT FOR SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY THREE AND
ESPECIALLY THANKS SENATOR --
SKINNER FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
PARTNERSHIP.
THIS BILL WILL ENABLE OAKLAND TO
THE CITY COUNCIL TO FOREMAN
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT TO SUPPORT THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF THE
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY ACRE.
HOWARD TERMINAL SITE LOCATED IN
WEST OAKLAND OR AT ANOTHER
LOCATION IF THE CITY COUNCIL
DECIDES -- IT WILL ALLOW US TO
FIND NEW PERMANENT HOME FOR THE
OAKLAND ETS -- MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL FRANCHISE AS WELL AS
PROVIDE JOBS WHICH SECOND LAST
REMAINING TEAM.
IT WE WE WE WANT TO KEEP THE A
IS AN OPEN ABSOLUTELY -- AT SO
IT'LL PROVIDE JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND CONTINUE TO
BUILD OUT EVEN MORE IN TERMS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND OTHER
COMMUNITY BENEFIT SO WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THE THE THE
POSSIBILITIES WHILE STILL --
SUPPORTING THE EXISTING.
NEIGHBORHOOD AT THE EXISTING
JOBS THAT EXIST AT THE PORT AS
WELL SO SB TWO NINETY THREE
PROVIDES.
ALL OF THAT FLEXIBILITY
ESTABLISH IT -- AND ALLOWS US TO
ESTABLISH AND OPERATE THE
DISTRICT IN A MANNER THAT
OPERATE OPTIMIZES.
ITS ABILITY OUR ABILITY TO
FINANCE MUCH NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE -- IS SHE A WITH
THAT -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I THOUGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I YES DAVE CAVELL A PRESIDENT OF
THE OAKLAND ETS -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON A VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FOR A NEW PRIVATELY
FINANCED BALLPARK IN OAKLAND WE
SPENT FIFTY ONE YEARS IN OAKLAND
WE'VE WON FOUR WORLD SERIES
CHAMPIONSHIPS WE BROUGHT A LOT
OF ENERGY AND EXCITEMENT TO OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND AS CENTER SKINNER SAID WE
ARE THE LAST PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
TEAM IN OAKLAND -- A CITY THAT'S
HAD A GREAT HISTORY NOT ONLY OF
PLAYERS BUT CHAMPIONSHIPS WE
WANT TO CONTINUE THAT FOR FOR
MANY GENERATIONS TO COME.
WERE COMMITTED TO BUILDING A
PRIVATELY FINANCED BALLPARK AND
THIS IS A GREAT TOOL TO ENABLE
US. TO REALLY TAKE THE NECESSARY
STEPS AND PARTNER WITH THE CITY
TO HAVE SUCCESS LOCALLY AND SO
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IT'S A PROJECT THAT WILL
GENERATE -- OVER SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC IMPACT SIX
THOUSAND PERMANENT JOBS TWO
THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION JOBS IT
REALLY IS A GAME CHANGER FOR
OAKLAND.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE ROB STOKER AND I'M
PROUD TO BE REPRESENTING THE
FORTY THOUSAND WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN.
AT THE ALAMEDA BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL AND WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I'M GETTING
A SENSE THAT.
LESS IS BETTER TODAY -- BUT
REALLY IT'S IT'S MORE THAN JUST
A GREAT PRIVATELY FINANCED
PROJECT IT'S ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PEOPLE IN OAKLAND -- THAT.
HOW WILL HAVE A PATHWAY CREATED
FOR THEM -- THE EIGHTIES IN THE
BUILDING TRADES ARE BOTH
COMMITTED TO GETTING LOCAL
RESIDENTS.
PLACED INTO OUR PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS AND THOSE ARE LIFE
CHANGING A PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS
FOR WHICH MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT
SO AGAIN WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WELL LOOKS LIKE YOU BROUGHT THE
TEAM.
A COLLECTOR GETS CON WHILE
OAKLAND RESIDENT -- FIRST FEMALE
**** IN ON THE U. S. ROWING
MEN'S NATIONAL TEAM WHICH TRAINS
ON THE OAKLAND ESTUARY FOR THE
TOKYO. TWENTY TWENTY OLYMPICS
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
PHIL TRUMAN RUBEN SEEN SUPPLY IN
OAKLAND OF WORK THERE TWENTY
THREE YEARS AND I'M.
DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
DENNIS DIFFER IS OUR WITH THE
USS HORNET SEA AIR AND SPACE
MUSEUM.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JAMES MANNER BECAUSE I WORK IN
OAKLAND AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
WARREN TO LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
OAKLAND BORN AND RAISED IN A
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THE POOR A SINGLE LOCAL RESIDENT
OF TWENTY ONE YEARS AS A FOUR
DAYS AGO AND STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
ROSS MELON OAKLAND RESIDENT
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SUSIE ALVAREZ SAN FRANCISCO
RESIDENT OAKLAND IS FAN AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL --
RYAN BRANDS BAY AREA RESIDENT
AND IS FAN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KEEP SALMON PRODUCER AND CO HOST
OF A BET ACTION ACE FAN RADIO
LIFELONG EAST BAY RESIDENT
MYSELF MY SIX COSTA COULD NOT
JOIN ME TODAY STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
I AM BATTLING DEAN THAT FOURTH
GENERATION ETS FAN AND THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR FOR
TEAMSTERS THREE FIFTEEN HEARD
ABOUT VOICE SUPPORT FOR MY LOCAL
AND OUR MEMBERSHIP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY STATE WITH PACIFIC
WORKING SHIPPING ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT OCEAN KERR'S MARINE
TERMINAL OPERATORS DOING
BUSINESS IN THE PORT OF OAKLAND
THANK YOU FOR PLANTS TO COMMENT
TODAY.
WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL -- IT'S
IT'S NOT NECESSARY BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THAN THAT IT ALSO
DOES NOT PROVIDE THE SAME TYPE
OF PROTECTIONS THAT EXIST IN
CURRENT LAW WITH RESPECT THE F.
T. I. F. THESE FOUR SEAPORT
DEVELOPMENT -- WE FIND THAT TO
BE A A REAL DEFICIENCY OF THE
BILL BUT MAKES A WATERFRONT SO
DESIRABLE TO THE A IS IS THE
SAME THING THAT MAKES IT
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE TO
PROTECT.
WHICH IS A ONCE WATER FROM
PROPERTY IS GONE IT'S GONE
FOREVER WE CANNOT USE IT AS A
PRODUCTIVE PART OF OUR WORKING
WATERFRONT -- YOU'LL HEAR FROM
OF THE STANDOFF MILE W. OF THAT
SOME OF THE VERY SPECIFIC ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE WITH RESPECT TO THE
ELIMINATION OF OUR WORKING
WATERFRONT OPPORTUNITIES TO GROW
THAT CARGO -- WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS THE STATE MOVES FORWARD
WITH AYE IF THESE -- THEY DO IN
A WAY WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH
SB -- SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR
HOLLINGS WAS PASSED SEVERAL
YEARS AGO.
THAT REQUIRES THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND THE SEAPORT TO
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE.
THAT PROVISIONS MOVING FORWARD
IN AN I FD PROCESS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S TRUST.
THIS AVOIDS THAT PROCESS
UNNECESSARILY.
IT WAS THE CITY COUNCIL IN
CONTROL OF STATE PROPERTY --
WHICH IS IMPROPER AND
INCONSISTENT WITH THE TRUST --
AND SO IT DOESN'T MEAN FAN THOSE
PROTECTIONS IN CURRENT LAW.
MORE OPPOSED TO THAT TO
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR OPPORTUNITY
GIVING US OFTEN THE COMMON ON
THOSE THINGS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WILL FOR THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED SB TWO
NINETY THREE FOR OF HAND FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS.
OTHER THAN THE OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE WITH ME
TODAY JUST REALLY BRIEFLY
MEMBERS WE ALWAYS BELIEVE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCE DISTRICTS --
IT SHOULD REQUIRE A TWO THIRDS
VOTE BEFORE BONDS CAN BE ISSUED --
I HAVE TIAS HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS IN STATUTE AND
THEY'VE ALWAYS REQUIRED A TWO
THIRDS VOTE AND WE BELIEVE THAT
SHOULD REMAINING IN PLACE -- FOR
THE SIMPLE REASON THAT LONG TERM
DEBT THAT'S GOING TO BE ON
PROPERTY TAX ROLLS FOR DECADES --
INCLUDING TAX INCREMENT SHOULD
REQUIRE A HIGHER VOTER THRESHOLD
AND THAT'S ALSO BECAUSE I IF
HE'S ARE TRADITIONALLY NOT
BACKED BY THE FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT OF A LOCAL GENERAL FUND.
THAT'S INCREASING RISK FOR BOTH
BOND HOLDERS AND TAXPAYERS AGAIN
ALL THE MORE REASON WHY YOU'D
WANT -- BROADER LOCAL SUPPORT
AND BY OFF -- BEFORE ISSUING
THESE BONDS SO FOR THOSE REASONS
ASPIRIN OVER [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS LISA AND ALL AND I AM
THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE. FOR
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF THE INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHORE WAREHOUSE UNION.
WHICH REPRESENTS SOME OF THE
MOST SKILLED AND HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED BLUE COLLAR LABOR IN
NORTH AMERICA.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO SB TWO NINETY
THREE BECAUSE IT WILL COST
OAKLAND TAXPAYERS HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ON UNNECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE IN
SUPPORT OF A LUXURY DEVELOPMENT
THAT WILL DESTROY GOOD PAYING
BLUE COLLAR JOBS THAT THE
OAKLAND RESIDENTS DEPEND ON THE
KANYE'S BASEBALL ORGANIZATION IS
QUICK TO STATE.
YES BALLPARK IN LUXURY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
PROPOSAL WILL BE PRIVATELY
FINANCED BUT SB TWO NINETY THREE
MAKES IT CLEAR THIS IS SIMPLY
NOT THE CASE.
THERE DEVELOPMENT WILL REQUIRE
OAKLAND TAXPAYERS TO KICK IN
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF TAX
DOLLARS TO BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE.
CLEAN UP A WORKING INDUSTRIAL
SITE.
IN AN INACCESSIBLE AND
COMPLETELY IMPRACTICAL AREA OF
OAKLAND.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE MY WORD
FOR IT IN THEIR SUPPORT LETTER
THE H. HAVE STATED THE PROJECT
CANNOT BE BUILT.
WITHOUT TAX INCREMENTS. TO SAY
THIS PROJECT IS PRIVATELY
FINANCED IGNORES THE VERY REAL
AND SIGNIFICANT COST TO OAKLAND.
OAKLAND NEEDS TAX DOLLARS GOING
TO FUND EDUCATION FIX CRUMBLING
ROADS IN SUPPORT EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
NOT HELPING BILLIONAIRES MAKE
MORE MONEY FROM LUXURY HOUSING.
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A LUXURY
DEVELOPMENT AND BALLPARK IN THE
MIDDLE OF OUR WORKING PORT.
WILL DISRUPT THE THRIVING
MARITIME INDUSTRY THAT ARE
WORKING WATERFRONT AND
JEOPARDIZE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
SEAPORT RELATED JOBS.
THE ACE PROPOSAL WOULD TAKE AWAY
CRITICAL SPACE BEING USED FOR
PORT OPERATIONS AND CREATE
SIGNIFICANT TRAFFIC DELAYS.
THAT WILL HINDER.
THE CONTINUED FUNCTIONALITY OF
THE PORT.
SEAPORT ACTIVITY AT THE PORT
SUPPORTS MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION IN DIRECT WAGES AND
SALARY FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
JOBS.
THAT SUPPORT THE LIVELIHOOD OF
MANY BAY AREA RESIDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE MARITIME
INDUSTRY IS EXPECTED ITSELF TO
CONTRIBUTE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE MILLION TO THE PORTS
OPERATING REVENUE.
THOSE THAT WORK AT THE PORT
EVERY DAY HAVE SAID LOUD AND
CLEAR THAT THIS PROJECT PUTS NOT
JUST THEIR JOBS IN JEOPARDY BUT
THE VIABILITY OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PORT.
IN ON ONE OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
PORTS ON THE WEST COAST
[inaudible]
AGAIN.
THIS IS A DEVELOPMENT DEAL PURE
AND SIMPLE IT INVOLVES A
VALUABLE REAL ESTATE AND LUXURY
CONDOS.
WHICH HAVE NOTHING TO DO.
WITH THE KIND OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT OAKLAND H..
WE RESPECT SICKLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO TAKE OUR CONCERNS
INTO CONSIDERATION AND VOTE NO
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS ARE
THERE ANY OTHER -- WITNESSES TO
OPPOSE THANK YOU YES MY NAME IS
NOT A MAKE A THE PRESIDENT OF
I'LL W. BUT WE CAN.
ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF THE SDDC
NOR THE COVERAGES ARE COUNCIL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
REASON ONE WE DON'T GET IN WILL
WATERFRONT LAND OKAY FOR LAST
THREE YEARS.
WE WILL MORE CARGO IN THE
HISTORY ABOUT IT BI<c.cyan>.</c>
OKAY WE'RE TRYING TO GROW.
THIS WILL ACTUALLY REDUCE LABOR.
WHEN YOU BUILD HOUSES AND
INDUSTRIAL LAND?
THEY WILL CRY LIKE HILL.
WE'RE MAKING TOO MUCH NOISE WE
WORK THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DAYS A YEAR TO GET THIS CARGO IN
AND OUT OF OAKLAND.
AND WE'RE DOING A GREAT JOB
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M AARON RIGHT I'LL W. LOCAL
TEN BUSINESS STAGING
REPRESENTING. THOUSAND WORKERS
LONG SO WORKERS BUT ALSO HERE
SPEAKING FOR THE TRUCKERS THE
RAILROADS.
AND GREATER NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY LIKE AGRICULTURE THE
MANUFACTURING AND RETAIL BECAUSE
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA IS THE THIRD
LARGEST PORT IN THE WEST COAST.
AND WE NEED TO KEEP IT THAT WAY
HOWARD TERMINAL.
IS A KEY LOCATION THEY WANT TO
PUT OF STADIUM SMACK DAB WHERE
RAY RHODES RUN THROUGH WELL WE
HAVE A TURNING BASIN FOR SHIPS.
AND THE TRUCKERS HAVE TO DRIVE
THROUGH THERE.
YOU BUILD OF STADIUM RIGHT HERE
IT'S GOING TO CHOKE OFF THE PORT.
MINIMIZE OUR COMPETITIVENESS AND
SHIPPERS WILL LEAVE WHEN THE
SHIPPERS LEAVE.
AND THIS WHOLE IDEA.
SENDS A MESSAGE TO THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
DO YOU WANT. TO SHIP TO THE
UNITED STATES THROUGH CALIFORNIA
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
OR DO I NEED TO SEND MY CARGO
ELSEWHERE SEATTLE ALONG LOS
ANGELES AGAIN RESPECTIVELY THANK
YOU.
AND FOR THE TIME AND PLEASE VOTE
NO.
THANK YOU.
MARIN PM WE HAVE A NATIONAL LONG
TERM WHERE HOUSE UNION -- AND
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY -- ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
YES.
YES -- THANK YOU FOR THIS
ACTUALLY WHEN I WAS -- DURING MY
GRADUATE WORK IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE AT A WHOLE PUBLIC POLICY
COURSE ON STADIUMS AND THE
IMPACT -- IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS
AND I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD BE
RELEVANT UNTIL TODAY -- I DO
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT WHY YOU'RE
SEEKING TO AVOID THE TWO THIRDS
VOTER APPROVAL WITH AN I FD
GENERALLY IT ALWAYS HAS HAD.
THE TWO THIRDS VOTER APPROVAL I
KNOW NOT MANY PEOPLE MAKE THAT
THRESHOLD COULD YOU EXPLAIN A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL.
I AM CERTAINLY THIS IS -- IT
REMOVES THE TWO THIRDS VOTER
APPROVAL BUT IT DOES INCLUDE
MULTIPLE PUBLIC HEARINGS IN A
PROTEST PROCESS -- CONSISTENT
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN
WITH PREVIOUS BILLS THAT HAVE --
PASSED THE PROTEST LANGUAGE ONLY
REQUIRES A 25% TO FILE AND THEN
IT DOES GO TO THE BALLOT -- THIS.
THIS WOULD NOT BE THE FIRST.
I'M THE I FD TO HAVE REMOVED
THAT TWO THIRDS -- BUT IT SB
NINE SIXTY ONE SENATOR ALLEN'S
BILL LAST YEAR THAT WAS CHAPTER
IT IS NOW IN EFFECT DID THAT --
BUT IT'S MOSTLY TO BE BROAD
PLANT IS THERE.
ARE VERY FEW RESIDENTS NOW.
BUDGET USUALLY THE I HAVE TO USE
THE RESIDENTS AROUND IN THE
SURROUNDING AREA.
AND WHILE THERE ARE SOME
RESIDENTS IN FACT ONE OF OUR
SPEAKERS HERE IS IN THAT SIR IT
IS THERE'S VERY LITTLE HOUSING
THERE NOW SO THERE'S VERY FEW
RESIDENTS AT THE MOMENT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
YES SO REMEMBER VOEPEL.
IN.
THIS QUESTION MAY BE A BETTER
DIRECTED AT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
EIGHTIES.
WHY BUILD A NEW STADIUM IN A
DIFFERENT LOCATION WHY NOT JUST
REDO YOUR STADIUM?
WHERE IT'S AT?
WELL IF YOU LOOK ACROSS -- NORTH
AMERICA THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
MAJOR LEAGUE STADIUMS ESPECIALLY
THE ONES THAT BEEN PRIVATELY
FINANCED OR BUILT IN DOWNTOWN
URBAN LOCATIONS.
AND THIS IS DOWNTOWN LOCATION IN
THE DOWNTOWN URBAN CORE OF
OAKLAND AS OPPOSED TO OUR
CURRENT SITE WHICH IS SIX MILES
SOUTH IN MORE OF A QUIET SIGH
INDUSTRIAL SUBURBAN LOCATION AND
SO.
A LOCATION WHERE YOU CAN WALK
BIKE AND ACTUALLY GET TO AND
FROM THE LOCATION -- THAT WAY IS
ACTUALLY LEAD TO MORE SUCCESS
AND SO THAT'S ONE OF THE KEY
REASONS AND IT BRINGS WITH IT
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS. TO THE
SURROUNDING AREA AND THE
DOWNTOWN CORE WHICH IS IMPORTANT
FOR THE CITY.
SO THE THINKING HE REASONS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE MOTION STILL -- WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS.
AND A SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY.
OKAY -- REJECT CLOSE.
I'M I APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
I WOULD ONLY INDICATE THAT THE
PORT OF OAKLAND IS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND OF THE STADIUM --
I APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS BY OUR
UNION MEMBERS THAT SPOKE.
AND SOME OTHER PORT AFFILIATES
THAT OF SPOKE IN OPPOSITION
BECAUSE OF THEIR CONCERNS THAT
MAY IMPACT PORT OF OPERATIONS --
WHILE I CANNOT TELL YOU WITH ALL
1100% CERTAINTY THAT IT WOULD
NOT HAVE ANY IMPACTS IMPORT
OPERATION CERTAINLY I LEAVE IT.
TO THE PORT OF OAKLAND ITSELF TO
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION AND IT
IS THEIR DETERMINATION THAT
ENHANCES AND THEY ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR OF
RAIN THE BILL FOR ALL THE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY IN
APPRECIATIVE CAN THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDED TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
IS THAT CORRECT.
YES AND IF I WOULD A NUMBER I
WOULD WRITE KLEENEX FOR YOU JUST
IN CASE THIS DIDN'T PASS BUT I
GOT A FEELING YOU'RE GOING THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION AS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HORROR THAT
RAMOS.
RAMOS CYBER THREE OF US THREE OF
US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL.
NOT VOTED VOEPEL NOT VOTING.
THE BILL SOUGHT.
SIX ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR.
WE NEED A MOTION ON THE SB TWO
THIRTY FIVE ONE LEFT.
WE HAVE A THEY HAVE ALL THAT
ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
RAMOS HISTORY.
THAT'S SB TWO THIRTY FIVE DODD.
THE SUN WE HAVE LEFT JUST AS A
WE DIDN'T HAVE A A QUORUM AT THE
TIME.
SERVICE.
WE HAVE MOTION SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS RAMOS
SEIDER THREE OF US IS RIVAS AYE
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL RIGHT
VOEPEL AYE.
MEASURES OUT SEVEN ZERO WE NOW
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON CALL THAT
WOULD BE YES -- I AND NUMBER TWO
SB ONE THIRTY NINE ELLEN THE
VOTE FOR LEASE [inaudible]
FOR THREE AT BOERNER HORVATH
[inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH HI.
WHEN YOU ADD ONS?
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT BELL THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ITEM FIVE SB TWO
NINE THREE SKINNER BOERNER
HORVATH.
BERNARD BACK NOT VOTING.
I WILL BE THERE ON FRIDAY.
I'LL BE ON SET.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ADJOURNED